[Música]
buenos días gracias
si pensáramos a todas las hormigas del
planeta su peso equivaldría al de todos
los seres humanos esta es una afirmación
que hicieron por primera vez el profesor
wilson de la universidad de hardware y
biólogo alemán gel doble en su libro de
1994 viaje a las hormigas evidentemente
nadie sabe cuántas hormigas en el
planeta aunque se estima que podrían ser
unos 100 billones con b es decir 100
millones de millones de individuos somos
demasiados seres humanos en el planeta
las previsiones es que alcanzaremos la
cifra aproximada de 10 mil millones de
individuos hacia el 2050 la mayor parte
de este crecimiento en países en
desarrollo particularmente en áfrica y
en asia permítanme que traiga este
argumento a lo falaz para llegar a
cuestión fundamental que es no cuántos
somos o seremos sino el modo en que
establecemos y satisfacemos nuestras
necesidades y que difieren evidentemente
del resto de las especies vecinas en
este planeta en común
todos los que estamos aquí o los que
vean están diferidos ciudadanos de la
sociedad avanzada consumimos anualmente
bienes y servicios cuya producción
distribución y desecho implican en
promedio unas 80 toneladas métricas de
materiales es decir como dos camiones
trailers de cinco ejes y seguro que
ahora mismo todos estamos pensando pero
es una pasa por mi carro de la compra y
por mi cubo de basura pero no olvidemos
que nuestro consumo fuera del hogar por
ejemplo cuando vamos al cine o vamos al
médico recordemos una autopista también
tiene implicaciones materiales hay
estadísticas que señalan que en torno al
80 por ciento de lo que compramos acaba
siendo un desperdicio antes del primer
año
si extrapolamos esta intensidad material
de la sociedad avanzada al resto del
planeta a esa proyección de población
que he mencionado necesitaríamos ya la
consabida fija de tres planetas tierra
para satisfacer nuestras necesidades
materiales y que evidentemente no
tenemos problemas que esta extrapolación
comienza a ser realidad
si actualmente vivimos aproximadamente a
la mitad de la población mundial en
zonas urbanas se espera que seamos más
de dos tercios en las próximas décadas y
en las ciudades se consume en torno al
75 por ciento de los recursos naturales
y en torno al 80 por ciento de la
generación mundial de energía
evidentemente de todas estas
proyecciones y todos estos procesos
migratorios de concentración en zonas
urbanas y sobre todo esta incorporación
de este crecimiento de la población en
países en vías de desarrollo a un modelo
equivocado expone a la sociedad a la
economía y al medio ambiente a grandes
riesgos riesgos de escasez y de
encarecimiento de materiales riesgos de
inseguridad abastecimiento de agua y
alimentos
en definitiva presión sobre los recursos
naturales
esta tendencia evidentemente también nos
puede derivar en grandes inestabilidad
es socioeconómicas y ambientales que tan
sólo podremos evitar ayudando al sistema
a transitar hacia un nuevo modelo de
producción y consumo más sostenible y
solidario con las generaciones futuras
en cuanto a los problemas estrictamente
ambientales la mayor parte de los
grandes problemas ambientales como
climático o la pérdida de biodiversidad
la erosión y degradación de los suelos o
la contaminación hídrica se caracterizan
por su deslocalización su gran
incertidumbre y la mayor parte de los
casos por la irreversibilidad de sus
consecuencias sacar la pasta del tubo es
fácil pero volver a meterlo es imposible
el hecho es que la sociedad la economía
consumista en la que actualmente vivimos
se fraguó hace más de un siglo y medio y
ha evolucionado desde entonces sin una
gran presión de la sostenibilidad
ambiental cuando los pioneros de la
revolución industrial como edison o
vanderbilt
fort contribuyeron al desarrollo de la
electricidad del ferrocarril o del
automóvil la sociedad del momento no
prestaba demasiada atención a esta
cuestión del medio ambiente ya lo
limitado de los recursos naturales que
entonces de hecho eran abundantes estos
líderes de la revolución industrial
probablemente ni siquiera llegaron a
pensar que la actividad humana llegaría
a dañar muy reversible al medio ambiente
si entonces hubiéramos sabido lo que
sabemos hoy sin duda habríamos diseñado
una economía distinta de la que
actualmente tenemos
la economía que tenemos es una economía
de 'usar y tirar' es una economía en la
que bueno pues estamos instalados desde
esa inercia de hace más de 150 años y en
la que se produce una cantidad de
residuos asombrosa lo que implica unas
pérdidas de valor igualmente
disparatadas el reciclaje de materiales
y la generación de energía con base en
residuos en europa apenas captura el 5
por ciento del valor original de las
materias primas existen numerosos
procesos y sectores que se consideran
actualmente maduros y optimizados pero
que son igualmente ineficientes se ha
mencionado en una ponencia anterior los
coches los vehículos privados permanecen
parados más del 90 por ciento del tiempo
la alimentación se pierde casi en un
tercio a lo largo de la cadena de valor
los edificios a las oficinas de trabajo
permanecen infrautilizadas entre el 35 y
el 50 por ciento del tiempo incluso en
horario laboral quizá tenga que ver algo
esto de salir a fumar la cuestión es que
en definitiva hay multitud de hechos
socioeconómicos que nos rodean que damos
por sentado que deben ser así y que son
altamente ineficientes la mayor parte de
los países avanzados muestra de ellos
europa con su plan para la economía
circular vigentes de 2015 pero también
muchas empresas comienzan a darse cuenta
que una economía lineal como la que
tenemos no se expone a grandes riesgos
en riesgos de volatilidad de los precios
de las materias primas riesgos de
posibles interrupciones de suministro
que afectan a la productividad de la
economía esta incertidumbre desalienta
inversiones empresariales eleva los
costes de protección frente a tales
riesgos y en definitiva están incidiendo
negativamente sobre el propio
crecimiento económico no es tan sólo una
cuestión de sostenibilidad ambiental
esta economía lineal reduce nuestras
posibilidades de progreso
en ese sentido debemos dar un paso atrás
y repensar cómo dar nuevas soluciones a
nuestros viejos problemas parafraseando
a einstein el mundo no puede evolucionar
más allá de su actual situación de
crisis utilizando el mismo pensamiento
que creó tal situación y dónde podemos
encontrar esa inspiración pues la
tenemos bajo nuestros pies la tierra es
nuestro único modelo sostenible es un
modelo de generación de valor que viene
funcionando ininterrumpidamente desde
hace 4 mil 500 millones de años con
3.500 millones de años y atendemos al
origen de la vida y venía funcionando
hasta hace unos 150 años con la llegada
de la revolución industrial si al lado
de la tierra le hiciéramos la
equivalencia a las 24 horas de un día a
la humanidad nos estaría gastando las
últimas milésimas de segundo del día
para poner en riesgo esta sostenibilidad
que viene desde hace millones de años
atrás
la cuestión es
que la tierra ha generado ha creado el
milagro de la vida con tan solo cuatro
grandes piezas pongámonos por un momento
delante de la caja de piezas de lego del
juguete el ego que regalan o regalamos a
nuestros hijos o sobrinos y nos abren
una mañana de reyes o después de su
cumpleaños con la intención de que la
montemos pero ya evidentemente montar el
diseño final y lo que es más interesante
desmontarlo dependerá del número de
piezas cuanto menos sea el número de
piezas más sencillo y del tamaño de esas
piezas cuanto mayor sea su tamaño
igualmente será más simple
el acrónimo son atiende a las cuatro
grandes piezas que ha utilizado la
naturaleza para crear el producto más
complejo y sostenible que podemos
imaginar la vida carbono hidrógeno
oxígeno y nitrógeno son los elementos
fundamentales quizá habría que añadir la
ape de fósforo necesario para la adn y
la clase azufre para los aminoácidos
pero bien con apenas media docena de
piezas la tierra nos ha demostrado ha
fabricado el producto más sostenible y
más inspirador que podríamos encontrar
pongamos ahora por contraposición el
ejemplo de un producto creado por la
mano del hombre
el automóvil se mencionaba la ponencia
anterior es una tecnología una alta
tecnología accesible a una parte de la
población mundial tenemos más de 1000
millones de vehículos mil millones
circulando ahí fuera bien con tasas de
crecimiento de los últimos años del 30
por ciento aunque evidentemente en los
últimos tiempos se produce cierta
ralentización la cuestión es cómo
deficiente es un coche en cuanto a su
producción su fabricación el número de
piezas de esta caja de lego es
notablemente superior a la anterior
verdad tenemos en promedio unas 80 mil
piezas en un vehículo tipo bien y más
que serán porque cada vez añadimos más
funcionalidades a nuestros coches la
cuestión es que con tal número de piezas
es francamente difícil sino imposible
recuperar todo el valor que se ha metido
originalmente en este diseño porque
desmontarlo y volver a recuperar ese
valor es muy costoso
y en cuanto a su uso para que
necesitamos un coche
para ir al trabajo para ir a la compra
para recoger a los niños en el cole
observa que más o menos todos estamos en
una forma física digamos aceptable vamos
a suponer un peso promedio por individuo
de 70 kilos
y vamos a aceptar cuando realmente lo
hagamos como dice las estadísticas un
uso fundamentalmente individual de
nuestros vehículos bien la cuestión es
que para desplazarnos al trabajo a la
compra o recoger a los niños para mover
nuestros 70 kilos de peso adquirimos la
propiedad de una tonelada de material es
que apenas utilizamos el 10 o el 5 por
ciento del tiempo y que no cambiamos al
poco tiempo si es que podemos por un
nuevo modelo desechando lo anterior
y previo a ello tenemos que meter a
veces semanalmente combustible en
nuestro depósito es un combustible una
energía que ha tomado a la naturaleza
millones de años crear sí y que es
malgastada en empujar este peso muerto y
en pérdidas de calor prácticamente todo
apenas un 5% de esa energía mueve
nuestra persona la movilidad personal ha
sido satisfecha esta necesidad humana de
una manera francamente mejorable cuando
henry fort hace un siglo se le ocurrió
tomó la decisión de poner un vehículo al
alcance de las masas se le atribuye la
frase si hubiera preguntado me habrían
respondido queremos caballos más rápidos
pero él decidió que no poner un coche al
alcance de cada familia bueno pues es
una decisión en la que estamos
instalados desde la revolución
industrial vamos a decir y qué bueno
pues cuesta francamente mucho cambiar
una vez que ya estamos en ella
bien la naturaleza nos muestra que los
procesos de creación de valor no son
lineales son cíclicos cuando tenemos
delante la fábrica que es la naturaleza
vemos que al final de su vida útil los
productos es decir los seres vivos
nosotros mismos cuando finaliza nuestra
vida útil permítanme que sea ácido frío
lo que implica es una retroalimentación
del sistema una reincorporación al
sistema natural sin pérdida de valor
para producir nuevos productos de igual
o mayor valor que los anteriores no hay
residuos es de hecho es deseable que el
residuo se convierta en alimentación
como no hay residuos pues no hay un
problema de gestión de residuos de hecho
es algo a celebrar la abundancia de la
producción y del consumo y su
crecimiento no se contrapone a la
sostenibilidad ambiental hay
oportunidades para imitar a la
naturaleza para la biomímesis en el
diseño de nuestros procesos económicos
no sólo de los materiales sino también
de los procesos industriales tenemos la
oportunidad para transitar hacia una
economía
la economía circular se apoya en tres
principios muy sencillos en primer lugar
como ya he dicho no hay residuos la
cuestión es que el diseño de los
productos debe pensarse desde el origen
con la intención del continuo de ese
ensamblado y reincorporación y
reintegración a los sistemas tanto
naturales como industriales bien segundo
principio debe haber una cuidadosa
gestión de los flujos de materiales los
materiales en términos de circularidad
pueden ser de dos tipos o en ser
nutrientes biológicos o naturales que se
reintegran al final de la vida útil de
los productos piezas por ejemplo que
tengan una composición que se pueda
desechar directamente la naturaleza sin
impacto negativo en el medio ambiente
esto supone una selección previa de qué
materiales y componentes se van a
utilizar esta reintegración en la
naturaleza implica un incremento del
valor del capital natural y por otra
parte nutrientes tecnológicos las piezas
o las partes al completo del producto
que una vez descartado desechado al
final de su vida útil se pueda
reintegrar de nuevo en el sistema
industrial sin pérdida de valor
de igual o mayor valor que los
anteriores contribuyendo este modo al
crecimiento del capital económico el
tercer y último principio la economía
circular es que todo esto debe ser
movido con energía renovable para
intentar evitar de nuevo el impacto
ambiental negativo e incrementar la
resiliencia de tanto el sistema natural
como el sistema económico todos los que
estamos aquí podemos contribuir a la
economía circular
basados en estos tres principios podemos
contratar en nuestros hogares energías
verdes podemos comprar electrodomésticos
más eficientes energéticamente podemos
consumir alimentos de temporada y
proximidad pero en definitiva sobre todo
debemos reducir nuestro consumo y
nuestros desperdicios y aunque la fuerza
de la demanda es poderosa y sin duda lo
que decidamos como consumidores como
ciudadanos
impacta en las decisiones de las
empresas esta transición esta
transformación es algo complejo costos
que exige o que bueno pues demandaría un
compromiso proactivo del lado de la
oferta de la de las empresas porque
implica inversiones inversiones de largo
plazo y por fortuna la mayor parte de
las inversiones y de los ejemplos de los
que disponemos en este sentido muestran
que se alcanza simultáneamente para las
empresas sostenibles ambiental y
sostenibilidad económica es decir
rentabilidad
tenemos algunos ejemplos inspiradores de
cómo las empresas pueden contribuir a la
economía circular incluso aunque no lo
hagan de modo premeditado es decir no es
necesaria una
visión de la cuestión ambiental para
contribuir a ella como ahora mostraré
las formas o modelos de negocio como se
llama en gestión a que pueden utilizar
las empresas para contribuir a la
economía circular son básicamente 5 en
primer lugar aprovisionamiento a la
industria de inputs de materias primas
ya sean renovables biodegradables o
reintegrables a los sistemas económicos
y naturales como explicado antes por
ejemplo bfc es una empresa canadiense
que produce fibras textiles a partir de
cultivos de lino y cáñamo que tienen
propiedades tan buenas como el algodón o
las fibras sintéticas que son
absolutamente integrales en la
tecnología de la industria textil
convicción convencional y que no tienen
evidentemente los impactos ambientales
negativos del algodón en términos de
consumo de agua o por supuesto el
problema de los residuos insostenibles
que son los micro plásticos no derivados
de los textiles sintéticos tenemos un
segundo modelo una segunda fórmula que
podría ser la
gestión del valor a lo largo de toda la
cadena productiva no solamente al final
procter and gamble opera más de la mitad
de sus fábricas con el objetivo de cero
residuos también está el modelo de
prolongación de la vida útil de los
productos se trata el final de bueno
pues recuperar los productos y
reacondicionar los y ponerlos de nuevo
al mercado como por ejemplo hace de un
cuarto modelo sería el negocio en
plataforma en vez de descartar o
despreciar o infrautilizar los recursos
facilitar el acceso o la copropiedad de
modo que sea más eficiente sus ejemplos
como el bien bio bla bla car y por
último producto como servicio en vez de
concentrarse en entregar una gran
cantidad de productos al mercado y
renovar cada cada equis tiempo el diseño
bueno pues entregar la utilidad lo que
realmente quieren los clientes
producto e iluminación como servicio de
philips por el cual el cliente compra
los lúmenes bellver no contra la
tecnología que se instalada mantenida y
actualizada por la compañía holandesa en
definitiva la transición desde el actual
modelo de economía lineal en el que
estamos instalados desde el siglo 19 y
al que se están incorporando
equivocadamente nuevas poblaciones y
nuevas generaciones y su transición
hacia la economía circular permitiría
compatibilizar los legítimos derechos de
esta población actual y la futura de
desarrollo y bienestar económico con las
capacidades naturales del planeta para
atender esas necesidades es sin duda un
proceso que no es sencillo se enfrenta a
una inercia de un siglo y medio pero
ofrece grandes oportunidades que se
valoran en torno a 4,5 millones de
dólares en los próximos años es sin duda
un proceso que será largo será lento
costoso frustrante probablemente a corto
plazo y pocas empresas y pocos países
podrán liderar pero seguro que esta
transición es algo de lo que pocos
podrán permanecer al margen
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y